I leave from the front right people I
don't I don't have people join me that
quit I've had stories where people said
I used to Chu chairs at people CH phones
at people I never knew that so maybe it
might be someone's dream but I don't
know but people might have this
perception about me it's jealousy beat
my track record I won two entrepreneur
of the year's Awards last year okay no
one's ever done that Great Britain and
the recruitment industry okay I believe
it's jealousy I believe it's people can
see that I'm going places but if you
look at my team they'll tell you the
type of leader I really am that's all
that matters that's all I care about
yeah now it's all I care about because
now it's about okay you can criticize me
but you can't criticize where my
business is going exactly and that's the
big difference and that's why I said to
you about the self-aware the
self-analyze the self-discovery and
stuff like that i' done that because I
wanted to be a better person yeah and
yeah I might have done some shitty
things in the past we all have exactly